we're gonna do it just being the mom is
labelled okay yeah let's go right thing
is not here
Oh for real yeah believe I'm doing this
Cesar I was a little nervous that Miss
Pat would be nervous and maybe she would
feel her energy and then there was so
much going on I thought maybe anything
could happen which one is it good tan
one nice an area here and everything
Thanks by offering his back to Nasir
Cesar hopes the dog won't feel
threatened sounds pretty happy right now
yeah she I was afraid to do eye contact
because I thought once he saw my eyes he
would try and climb over the fence miss
Paula bail is not blind okay she just
really I'm gonna look straight ahead
you're really amazing
now for this uh dog to be this calm
right now this is just it doesn't happen
yeah it doesn't happen and we've been
here for four years three we never see
oh yes a little bit miss party static Oh
Lord this is a challenge you know we're
challenging look I'm right here next to
you what you're gonna do nothing I got
it already slow slow slow
he's doing fine now she's doing
fantastic I am thrilled yeah but you
know what Cesar I feel embarrassed
because he's not showing out the way he
has been for the last three and a half
years which is actually a blast because
that makes it easier for his
rehabilitation thanks oh it's just a
lujah yeah so just the matter of time
for him to be in an environment what
they understand him and they challenge
him you know and then he can be around
other dogs and more people people who
don't have
this preconception about how bad he was
he's a good-looking guy is me beautiful
yeah if he was aggressive think you
would have lunch by now you know it's
just aggressive dogs you can't open this
gag without you know having some kind of
armor or something can I look now yeah
you can look through her after all right
oh he's beautiful well this is the first
I finally saw the color of his eyes oh
you never see them Cesar gets into the
cage next to Nasir to try and establish
more of a bond with the dog
everybody gets intimidated by the size
they don't get to see what he's coming
from they don't get to feel insecurity
they don't get to feel nervousness they
just see aggression